foreign
[Music]
for four today hey dude lol slow Devin
uploaded his defense no I didn't even
mean to do that in his voice I'm gonna
go on my YouTube channel against the
advice of my lawyers oh no Diddy Diddy
really
oh no Hannibal you are not going the
right angle with this oh boy oh boy all
right we got all right we got all your
watches before we do Daniel oh boy by
the way Brian last and Jim cornette also
did a great take on Hannibal I had it
first sorry boys but um still at a very
funny base take on this idiot
um so for those of you that don't know
you can watch the night wave from Friday
um Hannibal our favorite Blood Hunter
was uh arrested for assaulting a woman
suspected to be as at the time
girlfriend a woman I suspect to be that
prostitute Natalia that he was hanging
out with that it was very clear he was
paying for company from
10 000 noodles says that dog looks like
your cats could beat its ass Louis might
but
Clarence is a [ __ ]
Frozen agent I do it for the content I
do it for the blood all right here it is
boys
yeah Matt the one he's been working out
with
this is Hannibal here with Piper my
lovely dog and the mascot of the
Hannibal TV and yeah if I was just
listen if I was implicated by the police
in physically assaulting a woman who
might be a prostitute
I'd probably start the video holding
both my cats I feel you brother
unfortunately a situation has come up
that there's a lot of people please do
tell that are trying to make me guilty
until proven innocent
and unfortunately uh a bad situation
happened with uh a girl that I was
dating which one but one thing that's
one which one which one which one which
one which one that's all I want to know
I need to know if I'm right I need to
know if I called this from the beginning
nobody is reporting on
is the girl manasqui Mona Yates
actually also has five charges whoa okay
buddy
hang on
I I believe
can somebody find me this woman by the
way
um
it looks like the Blood Hunter has
become the blood Hunted
The Blood Hunter has become the blood
prey
so I'm pretty sure this look and I I'll
bullet like I'll listen inside but I'm
sure that this hooker flipped out on him
or something happened something weird
happened
but
but
when you at Hannibal
I understand
like
you know paying for lap dance whatever
hell I understand paying for a hooker
especially if you're in the right part
of the country the right time right
place you're partying in Vegas or
something it's a great time to get a
hooker you know this time you know
whatever you go to a rage massage joint
whatevs I'm not against I'm not being a
moral [ __ ] here when I say this Hannibal
I'm gonna quote several Great Western
philosophers when I tell you
you cannot make a hoe into a housewife
if if it's the loneliness that's
bothering you get a friend get another
dog
but
when you
when you start to take on like it's one
thing to get a hooker
have a fun night with her you know go
out to dinner a couple drinks romp in
the sheets
and the best part is especially if
you're staying at like a hotel or
something door locks itself behind her
she lets herself out you [ __ ] get a
nice nice [ __ ] night's sleep
but when you start spending time
with these hoes
you're
constantly
increasing the chances that you're gonna
have a [ __ ] disaster
just saying
you hang around
like I said romping the sheets have a
fun night have a nice night godspeed to
you
but when you start doing this
she's helping me hunt blood
are you doing all that weird ice cream
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] that flirty oh I know
I could tell right now
if he just got out of jail hang on let's
see something let me see something here
no she's still on the channel okay maybe
this isn't the same chick maybe Natalia
is one that he was
you know hoeing it up with a little bit
um and then moved on I need to hear this
name
actually that nobody is reporting on
is the girl manasqui Mona Yates
menaski Mona Yates how would you even
spell that
I wouldn't even know how to
like
I mean I
it's a strip her name yeah I don't know
it's probably a Christian name because
he's probably using it like a power word
um
that's not her it's like an 80 year old
white woman
menaski Mona Yates that's what I'm
saying yeah and I looked it up but I
don't know where the [ __ ] like you're
spelling it about as good as I possibly
could
Wade's world
actually also has five charges against
her
for assaulting me with a weapon
uttering threats to me
uh destroying my property
and causing me bodily harm so there's
two sides to the story she's already had
one court appearance
in Ottawa September 2nd she has another
one October the 7th
and I'm gonna leave it up to the courts
I it's not a matter of public opinion
um it's a matter for the courts to
decide and it's an unfortunate situation
and it's time for the only female I
could trust actually I could trust my
ex-wife
uh and there are some others out there
but
um it's it's just an unfortunate
situation all around
I've never been in a situation like this
before
uh where I've had to deal with a partner
attacking me
and um
it's just unfortunate I I
can't say anything more than that
I wish her the best but it's now a
matter before the courts thank you for
sir you shouldn't have gone up there you
should not I'm not here to watch hunting
are you not
oh my God
[ __ ] give a [ __ ] about The Honky Tonk
Man the only Honky Tonk Man I could need
is this fake one coming out of your
check you [ __ ] Mark
thank you
taper says uh Hannibal and Michael Elgin
should start a podcast together they can
talk slow and talk [ __ ] about women
being the root of all their problems
together
oh [ __ ] man
[ __ ] stupid blood hunting [ __ ]
I mean what a [ __ ] yeah you're right it
really deserves every one of them what a
mark that's cause you're a mark you
[ __ ] Mark